Hello everybody and welcome to another
episode of my 1hour flipping challenge.
Today we're going to be tackling
Dagenoth King Drops. And I can tell you
right away this is the most profitable
episode I have ever done. I was at the
suggestion actually of someone in the
clan chat. Unfortunately, your name
slipped my mind, but you know who you
are. So, thank you for that awesome
suggestion.
And uh yeah, without further ado, let's
jump into it. Okay, we're about to get
started. So, we have 30 mil in the
inventory. We're going to be flipping
Dagenoth King drops
for 1 hour. Um, all the Dagenoth Kings,
Dagenoth Prime, Dagonov Rex, Dagenoth
Supreme, and yeah, let's see how this
goes. So, we'll hit 1 hour on the clock
and let's go. So, we are going to start
with um the archer ring, maybe
archer
ring.
And uh we'll put it in for
2K maybe.
And we'll start with
three cuz they will buy quickly, but
we'll see if we actually have the right
price first. Uh next to some warriors
rings.
Um I mean, sorry, berserker rings. We
might do the warriors ring, but we're
going to have to see
how often they're actually traded.
Berserker ring and we'll put it in for
39 to five six
and do two of those or something to
start with. Um, put in four 158
and we'll just put in all eight, which
is the buying limit for that. Okay,
we've actually bought a Berserker ring
already and a Warriors ring. So, that's
pretty good. Just a bit below the
actively trade price. So, 3951
and we instantly sold it.
Okay. And we'll put this other one as
well. Um the OS buddy prices showing it
much higher. Uh we'll just do two
to start with cuz they don't trade that
much. And um we have sold both the
Berserker rings already. So, that's
another 50k profit right there. That's
going quite nicely to begin with here.
And we have flipped three of the
Berserker rings. Four of the Berserker
rings. My god.
[Music]
And we bought uh all the Sears rings as
well. So, we'll just put those in there.
We'll see if they sell first. We sold
another Berserker ring. And we bought
another one. Um maybe someone checked
the margin there, but we'll see. 11304.
We'll just do 200 for now. Okay, so we
are back. Um, we have sold all the
warriors rings already and uh we got a
couple more to sell, but wow, that was
quick. And we've actually sold a Sears
ring as well, so pretty decent. Might go
buy a couple more of those pretty soon.
And uh
just do five for now. 95k,
96k,
and I believe the limit is just eight on
this as well. Um, so we'll just pull the
Daglop bones out now just to see um how
quickly they sell before we start buying
a larger amount. That's actually pretty
decent. That's a 60k profit. So, we'll
see how quickly those sell.
Um, and we've sold another Berserker
ring. I just cannot stop talking really.
Okay, we sold another Sears ring for
another like 30k profit or so. So,
that's awesome. We're just going to move
the offer up here and maybe up it by
one. Torsal seed has a 500 GP margin.
Sure, let's do it. 3570 and we'll start
with 100. Um, that'd be an easy 100k.
Um, the right price.
Yeah. Okay. So, we finally bought a
archer ring um for 301.
Um, so I think we'll pop it in here just
somewhere. 3020k.
Okay. So, we've actually sold all the
berserker rings, which is nice. We get
more room back. All three sold there.
Um, we've sold all of the archer ring.
The archer ring, sorry.
Uh, which is nice. And, uh, we still
have to buy one more of these. Uh, never
mind. We just bought it. Okay, so that
seems to be the right price. Um, so
we'll put in for 3019.
Okay, so we have sold the archer ring as
well. Uh, giving us another 320k or
something like that. And we sold a good
portion of these Dagenoth bones as well,
which is pretty sweet. And we are one
away from buying all of these sear
rings. So, let's leave it in here for
another minute cuz we're only 40 minutes
in so far.
And we'll just do 200 because I know
this is a quick item. It wouldn't take
too long. Try
yeah 20 to start with here. Okay. So, we
have actually bought two of the archers
rings. Um bought pretty much all the
torso seeds. Uh so we'll pull that out.
And we also want more importantly
probably to sell these uh which were
going for 3019k. We had to raise it up.
So this margin is not that great. Uh, we
popped it up twice and then we finally
bought them for 307500.
Um, we got a bunch of these sear calls
actually. So, we got six of those and
we're just kind of running out of spot.
I think we'll leave this archer helm for
now. We need the spot more importantly.
Um, I think we'll put these sear callull
in. And the actively trade price is 114.
[Music]
once again has like a
70 limit on it I believe and we'll start
with 40 and see how quickly that goes.
We bought another archer ring as we put
it in for
eh not a huge profit again.
Okay, we're just going to pull this
dagon bones out. We got a decent amount
of money there, but they sell in weird
chunks and this could take a long time
just to sell this last 15. So, we'll
dump the rest of those quickly. And uh
we still like to buy the majority of
these, so we'll put another offer in for
those. All the archer rings have bought,
so we're just kind of waiting for them
to sell now. Okay, so we actually sold
all these Sears rings, which is nice. Um
fully flipped the Sears rings, I think.
Can't actually remember correctly now. I
think there might be a couple missing. I
don't know. Um but the circlls, we
actually sold a couple of those and
that's a pretty big profit on the
circle. We bought them for 90k,
I believe. 96k, and we're selling them
for
um 114. So, pretty good price. Anyway,
okay, so all these snapdragon seeds sold
in one go, which is quite nice. Um
someone must have been prepping for some
farming, but uh it's kind of hard to
know how much we made cuz we bought them
in two chunks, but I think we got 500 GP
profits. That's like 100k right there,
actually. And we finally sold an archer
ring for a
There's another one. I don't know, like
under 10k profit on each one, but you
know, it's still money. Oh my god,
there's a third one. They're all selling
at once now. Okay, death runes have a
3GP margin on them right now. And we
still have half an hour left, so let's
do it. 10,000 and reduce a bit. 9 012.
That's a pretty good margin for battle
stavs.
8964,400
[Music]
battle stabs 12 mil. Let's go. Should be
9012 minus 8964*400
should be about 67k. Okay. And it should
be a very quick flip, but just never end
ups working for some reason. Um, the
arch rings are totally sold. So, that's
nice to get that out of the way.
Okay. So, we didn't buy a single battle
staff. That means the margin has already
changed. Uh, cuz they normally come in
extremely quickly. This is weird. Why
can't I buy a battle staff?
There's no way that no one's just not
selling one. What the [__] Okay, that's
just weird. What did we buy a ballast
for? 10819.
That's not right.
9347.
Look how volatile that is. It changed so
much. Um
I mean, if you if I had bought battle
staff, that would have been amazing. But
I think we're just going to leave it for
a minute. But maybe come back to that in
a sec. These always seem good in
practice before I actually try to sell
them. 160
and 10,000.
And we actually sold another circle. So,
this item is definitely paying off in
the long run. All right. I think we're
going to do the mud battle staff. Um,
put it in for 131k.
Yeah, I have to put in for 10. I'm not
sure what the buy limit is on this
actually. Okay, so we have sold all the
death runes and we got a 5 GP margin in
those. That's quite nice actually. All
right, let's go check battle stabs
again.
Hopefully they're not super They are
still not buying. Okay, I might risk
this then because this could be a
massive amount of profit.
This is really risky. I'm gonna say it
now.
We're just going to do 500. H, this is a
bad idea.
Okay, so we've sold all these circles
and we definitely want to get Wow, we
bought five more battle styles already.
Okay, now is the moment of truth and see
if
there is still nobody selling it.
Oh my god, this building for 900
or
I don't know
11926. Okay, so we bought them for 4675
and we're selling for what? No way. Oh
my god, we just sold 100 of them.
Oh my god, guys. We just sold all the
battle savs.
What?
Look at that difference. One point. Oh
my god. We got We got to buy more of
these. There's one. Oh my god. Forget
about everything. They are not buying
for 13k. What is wrong? Do another 500.
We're going to be cautious here. Okay.
Oh my god. Our battle savage just
instantly bought. Okay. Put them in
four. We sell 11700. Let's just leave
that in there and just hope we got to
deal with our other stuff. But we really
want to do this first. Uh law runes 213.
Uh sell them for 215.
We sold one, but okay. We'll put them in
for a little bit more of a reasonable
price and hope 10,900.
It's a less of a profit, but we only
have 12 minutes left and we want to sell
these. We want for 4,700.
That's still a huge profit even if we
sell half those. Okay, we sold all the
mud battle stabs. That was actually
relatively quick. Um, it might be too
late to buy more, but still. Uh, bought
them for 393k and sold them for 432K. a
pretty nice profit for a very cheap
item. I would probably do that at some
point. Um, okay, we've actually sold 101
of the battle stavs for another pretty
hefty chunk of profit right there. That
is amazing. Okay, we've sold another 100
battle stavs.
I don't believe it. Who would actually
buy these for this price? Uh, not
selling those. Oh my god, the battle
stabs have totally sold.
minus one or something. That is a crazy.
I don't even know how much we made on
that, but I don't even remember. I think
we made another 500 600k on that. That
is insane, guys. Six minutes left. Let's
just see what we can sell here. I have
one battle staff left and now I'm just
kind of interested. I'm just going to
put in for 20. No, no, there's no Maybe
someone will need a battle staff really
badly. Put in for 20k. Okay, we
instantly sold them for 164. So 4k in
profit there. Not too bad. A lot of
runes are coming in very slowly. Uh but
they're coming in still. What is going
on here? Look, I legitimately have a buy
price in for battle stabs for 14k.
There is no one selling this item.
Okay, I just bought a battle staff for
14k. [__]
Okay, guys. Excitement aside, we only
have 30 seconds left. So, obviously the
MVP for this episode was the battle
staff by far, but let's not forget about
the Berserker ring right away, which did
quite well as well. And um the Seir Call
was a pretty decent item as well. The
mud battle staff I think would have been
better had I bought more early on, but I
didn't realize would actually trade that
quickly.
Honestly, this was probably the best set
of items I could have done. Um, tons of
highly traded items. If I got a better
margin on the archer ring, would have
got even more. Crazy. Anyway, that's it,
guys. Timer's done. And let us sell
everything and see how much we actually
made. So, we'll pull all our offers out.
Uh, dragon axes didn't sell. Um, only
half of them. They're pretty slow, but
they do work pretty decent. Torsal seeds
didn't work at all. Battle staff.
And yeah, let's start selling off the
items. Law runes 298.
dragon axes
and the torso seeds
and the one lone battle staff as well as
the archer helm.
Okay, so everything insta sold. Let's
hit that collect button and boom, we're
at 32 mil. That's exciting. The first
time we've ever gotten 2 mill plus in
one episode. So let's have a quick look
at how much money we got from flipping
Dagenoth Kings for 1 hour.
32.3 mil. That is quite nice. 2.3 mil in
profit. Um, again, I just flooked out on
the ballast stabs. That was probably a
solid 1.5 mil of that. So, more than
half. So, that is I It's a little bit
inaccurate, but I mean it's an it's
opportunistic. You have to take the
opportunity. Of course, it was possible
I could have lost a lot of money, but
not nearly as much as I gained. So
anyway, I hope you guys enjoyed and I
will see you guys in the next episode.
[Music]